le temps d'une journée le stade gravaud
a pris des allures de fête foraine pour
trappe en fait une manifestation qui
existe depuis plus de 50 ans et qui se
veut festive et fédératrice
on s'adresse exclusivement dans un
premier temps aux trappistes bien
évidemment mais on a beaucoup de gens
qui viennent a aussi d'autres villes on
est toujours un peu sur l'éducation
populaire donc la participation très
important effectivement la culture pour
tous pour cette édition 2010 9 une
vingtaine d'activités étaient proposées
au public les arts du cirque étaient à
l'honneur grand chapiteau avec
spectacles mais aussi des ateliers
d'initiation
non c'était pas dur il faut pas dire
c'était facile ça fait une petite sortie
c'est gratuit en plus faut pas se voiler
la face 1
et voila quoi les enfants sont contents
ils s'amusaient des contenus d'autres
activités au programme également des
concerts et des déambulations avec une
météo parfaite tous les ingrédients
étaient réunis pour le plus grand
bonheur des participants cette année je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup plus activité à
un cirque eux il ya des vrais manège et
voilà au fait quelque part ça le fait
sortir c'est comme s'il était quelque
part dans une fête foraine quoi tu m'as
léger avec l'été qui n'ont jamais placé
et après après on va y aller
réciter des cas qu'on va manger une part
tapas par une édition 2010 9 réussi pour
trappe en fait puisque cette
manifestation a accueilli plus de 14
mille cinq cents personnes